com
c-span
join american history tv this weekend as
we visit charleston south carolina
we're visiting one southeastern city
each month to learn more about its rich
history
our next charleston stop is the old
slave market to hear about one of the
largest slave trading and selling hubs
in the confederacy
we are sitting in the former sales room
for the ryan smart auction complex
we're up on the second floor but
originally this building didn't have a
second floor there was just a long
narrow
building that was part of a complex of
four buildings that made up ryan's mart
we know that charleston played a very
significant role during the
transatlantic slave trade
and it was a major port of entry for
enslaved africans coming into what is
now the united states
about 40 percent of all enslaved
africans coming into this country
in 18th century entered through the port
of charleston
but the transatlantic slave trade was
abolished in 1808 although there was
much smuggling
but what we focus on here is the
domestic slave trade since the majority
of enslaved people who
were sold here at ryan's more were
american born they were the children
grandchildren and great-grandchildren of
those enslaved africans that had been
brought here against their world
generations before in 1856 when we see
the first advertised slave sale here
the 20 year old woman named lucinda this
building wasn't even here and if you
look at the walls around us you'll
notice that
this was actually an alley it was an
alley that led into the larger auction
complex and there were three buildings
there the main building
was a four-story jail or barracoon and
that's where enslaved people were held
before sale
there was also a two-story structure
that was used as a kitchen there was
also a smaller structure in the
southwest corner of the lot
that was described as a dead house or a
morgue and if the slave trader knew that
there was an enslaved person in that
jail that was sick they would remove
that person to this other structure so
as not to
infect the
larger population thousands of enslaved
people were sold here between 1856 and
1863.
the largest
slave sale that i know about that was
advertised was 256 enslaved people
in
today's dollars
a very
enslaved man who is in the prime of his
life very strong and able-bodied could
be sold for
in today's about 35 000
and of course if you had a special trade
or skill you would be worth more
enslaved people had to be
prepared for sale
especially if they
had traveled from a great distance if
an enslaved person let's say they were
coming from
richmond virginia
and coming here to ryan smart to be sold
that could take
weeks or months
traveling on a good day about 20 miles
20 to 25 miles a day so it could take a
long time and by the time they got here
to ryan smart they definitely wouldn't
be in any condition to be sold they
would be bruised probably with
with the shackles and chains they'd been
wearing especially the men who were
shackled the entire time
uh very thin
uh dirty
they were in no position to be sold on
the auction block a potential buyer
um
wouldn't
wouldn't want to purchase them so
arriving in a place like this this
auction complex
thomas ryan and then later zb oaks would
have a staff
of uh black and white enslaved and free
people here working to get
those people who were coming to be sold
ready for the auction block enslaved
people were fed very well before auction
trying to fatten them up
they would also be provided soap and
water here at ryan's mart to
wash themselves and sometimes
they would also be given palm oil or
some other kind of oil and encouraged to
rub that into their skin
so
that
they could appear healthier and their
muscles would look more defined and they
would look bulked up so all that would
happen and of course the last thing that
had to happen
was that people had to
find out when that auction was was going
to happen
and
so ads would have been placed in the
local papers
and some of those larger slave auctions
would be advertised throughout the
southeast
so if you were a slave trader in the
south and someone said ryan smart you
would know they would know
where you were talking about
enslaved people you would think that
they wouldn't have any agency they
wouldn't have any power in a situation
like this or maybe as they stood on an
auction block no power
um
they knew they were going to be sold but
there were things that they did for
instance if there was a
enslaved man who was
on the auction block and
a
potential buyer started bidding on him
a potential buyer who he knew of
maybe he would start speaking up and
saying you know if you buy me
um i will work for you i work very hard
for you sir and and maybe start bragging
about how how strong he was or or
um
how skilled he was and maybe even try to
encourage that
buyer
to purchase his wife and child also and
and so enslaved people did that and it
wasn't because they were happy with
their
their
um
lot in life or happy about being
enslaved or content
this man was trying to keep his family
together and he was going to do anything
and say anything to
to achieve that
the last advertised slave sale
here at ryan's mart occurred in november
1863 and it wasn't until about a
1936 that miriam wilson
purchased the building
and she
knew and many people knew that this was
a place where enslaved people were sold
and she wanted to
open this building as a museum
so she established the old slave mart
museum
in 1937 and um opened i believe in
march of that year so opened this
building as the first african-american
museum in the country
all weekend american history tv brings
you the history of charleston south
carolina
to learn more about our tour of eight
southeastern cities
visit cspan.org
local content
we're standing in a place that we call
chin ridge it's the farm of benjamin
chin